we begin in afghanistan where the
taliban says u.s and allied forces must
leave the country by the august 31st
deadline as agreed thousands of troops
are deployed in kabul where they're
carrying out the biggest humanitarian
airlift in history the evacuations have
been chaotic and there are reports that
unidentified gunmen have killed a man at
cowboy airport during a fire fight
involving western security forces well
u.s president joe biden says his forces
have expanded the perimeter around the
airport to accelerates the evacuation
process and while those evacuations are
underway the taliban says it has sent
fighters to panshire to counter
anti-taliban forces the group says it's
looking to negotiate rather than fights
well for more on this uh let's start at
the airport we can speak now to al
jazeera's charlotte bellis he joins us
on the phone
uh charlotte you're at the airport just
give us a sense of what the situation is
like right now
[Music]
right we're about 500 metres from the
north gate which is where everybody has
been asked or has been the last few days
been asked to go through uh thousands
thousands of people cramped
trying to get through but the gate is
fully shut there we have
uh western security forces
fence line
uh but there's really no movement it is
incredibly hot down here they are
dehydrated
um
where we've moved down to we're
essentially in the no man's land that's
being controlled by uh special
caa-funded
units that used to come under the afghan
intelligence school they have been
shooting in the air you just tear a
gunshot there
to disperse crowds and they are
essentially
controlling this area between the gate
that is shut
and the taliban and to get to this area
we had to move through taliban special
forces so
uh to give you a little bit of
appreciation of really how hard it is if
you have a
u.s citizenship passport any type of
western evacuees afghan evacuees to get
through this is the type of gordon you
have to run
and and charlotte we're also hearing
reports of a fire fight at the airport i
i appreciate you caught in the crush
right now and it's it sounds like a very
challenging situation uh to put it
mildly but have you and your team
learned anything more about that
firefight at the airport we understand
one person has been killed
we did ask about that at the north gate
where it was reported to have happened
uh people that have been here like
there's school pieces and things that
people have set up here they said there
was a big fire fight but it happened
late yesterday uh and that they know
that uh western forces were involved in
that uh we are some of these nds units
these afghan forces if they were
involved in the fight uh and they
directed us further down to the north
gate there's still a lot of confusion
but there's also a lot of uh gunfire
happening just as hard as crowd
dispersal uh they're also beating people
in front of us
uh it is uh anarchy and and chaotic and
there are children here there are women
here
uh and thousands of people
okay uh charlotte bellis uh we'll let
you go and and try and get to a place of
safety if one exists but thank you for
uh giving us a sense of the chaos and
anarchy
happening around kabul airport we
appreciate it speak soon
well let's uh cross over now to rob
mcbride he is live for us in kabul uh
rob we've been hearing about the ongoing
chaos there at the airport but uh
another interesting development that has
happened
in the last hour or so is that taliban
announcement that it's not going to
extend the deadline for western forces
to withdraw is rather interesting is it
not given a lot of the discussion
in uh
uh in the us and the uk is all about
trying to stay there as long as
necessary to get people out what more
are you hearing
yeah i mean it's interesting wording
about uh the the taliban giving
permission to extend i mean is it for
them to give permission i mean this
deadline has been something of a
moveable feast uh remember that may the
first was set as the first deadline for
uh u.s and nato forces to withdraw from
afghanistan that was agreed under the
peace deal with the taliban under the
trump administration last year now also
as part of that deal the taliban agreed
to talk to the ashraf ghani government
at the time well they didn't hold those
talks so when biden joe biden announced
in april he was extending the deadline
to the symbolically important september
11th they felt justified in doing so the
the thinking being well if the taliban
can break the deal we can break it too
so they biden the extent of the deadline
and then this august the 31st deadline
was again put in place by joe biden that
was put in place in july he brought
forward effectively his own deadline and
so he set it to august the 31st if he
set it then presumably he can unset it
which he seems to be doing now because
of what's going on at the airport also
at the urging of boris johnson of the uk
so
i what what the taliban will do it
remains unclear they have said they
won't allow an extension it's a red line
they have in the past warned that when
they extended the last time they were
going to target u.s
forces they didn't do that it remains
very doubtful that they would do it at
this stage because they have an awful
lot of other concerns rather than a
continuing scrap with the americans
they've got a country to run they've got
to get a country to get in order they've
got to deal with relations with their
neighbors try to unfreeze assets abroad
and everything else that running a
country involves so you do get a sense
that although they're going to talk
tough they probably it's in everybody's
interest that they do give the us the uk
and its allies
the extra days it needs to get the
people out and the taliban can get on
with running the country well they have
to get on with running the country as
you say rob but there's also uh
rumblings about uh a nascent resistance
uh movement uh what more can you tell us
about this
yeah this is in the panshir valley
that's north of kabul it's uh
it is the traditional home of resistance
to the taliban it was the home of the
northern alliance 20 years ago that was
the springboard for the u.s to intervene
after the twin towers came down and
sweep the taliban from power so it was
the natural place that a resistance
would form again and it's the son of
armacha massoud the lion of panchaya who
is something of a a hero especially
among the tajik community a resistance
fighter he has been in the panshir with
around 22 500
troops and also a couple of government
ministers from the collapsed regime but
it's it's difficult to say how serious a
resistance this is there is speculation
that uh massoud may have been in
negotiations to uh to
basically put down their arms and to
support the government that seems to
have gone away there might be some
resistance but we do know that the
taliban themselves are taking this
seriously and they're pretty much
surrounded the valley with uh superior
forces so it is something of a standoff
but it remains to be seeing if the
resistance has the force
to survive this okay rob mcbride there
joining us live from kabul with the
latest developments thank you rob